so in 2011 someone broke into my
sister's office at the University where
she teaches in Nigeria now thankfully if
the person was caught arrested and
charged to court but I get into court
the clerks who were assigned to my
sister's case informed her that they
wouldn't be able to process the
paperwork
unless she paid a bribe at first she
thought it was part of a practical joke
but then she realized they were serious
and then she became furious I mean think
about it here she was the recent victim
of a crime with the very people who were
supposed to help her and they were
demanding a bribe from her that's just
one of the many ways that corruption
impacts millions of people in my country
you know growing up in Nigeria
corruption permeated virtually every
element of the society reports of
politicians and bezzle millions of
dollars were common police officers
stealing money or extorting money from
everyday hard-working citizens was
routine practice I felt that a
development could never actually happen
so longest corruption persisted but over
the past several years in my research on
innovation and prosperity I have learned
that corruption is actually not the
problem hindering our development in
fact conventional thinking on corruption
and its relationship to development is
not only wrong but it's holding many
poor countries backwards so the thinking
goes like this in a society that's poor
and corrupt our best shot at reducing
corruption is to create good laws and
force them well and this will make way
for development and innovation to
flourish now make sense on paper which
is why many governments and development
organizations invest billions of dollars
annually on institutional reform and
anti-corruption programs but many of
these programs fail to reduce corruption
because we have the equation backwards
you see societies don't develop because
they've reduced corruption they're able
to reduce corruption because they've
developed and societies developed
through investments in innovation now at
first I thought this was impossible why
would anyone in their right mind invest
in a society where you know at least on
the surface seems a terrible place to do
business
you know such society where politicians
are corrupt and consumers are poor but
then the more I learned about the
relationship between innovation and
corruption the more I started to see
things differently
here's how this played out in
sub-saharan Africa as the region
developed its telecommunications
industry in the late 1990s fewer than 5%
of people in sub-saharan Africa had
phones in Nigeria for example the
country had more than a hundred and ten
million people but fewer than half a
million phones in the whole nation now
this scarcity fueled widespread
corruption in the industry I mean public
officials who worked for the state-owned
phone companies demanded bribes from
people who wanted phones and because
most people couldn't afford to pay the
bribes phones were only available to
those who were wealthy then an
entrepreneur named Mo Ibrahim decided
that he would set up a
telecommunications company on the
continent
and when he told his colleagues about
his idea they just laughed at him but
Muybridge was undeterred and so in 1998
he set up cell tell the company provided
affordable mobile phones and cell
service to millions of Africans in some
of the poorest and most corrupt
countries in the region
I mean countries such as Congo Malawi
Syria Lyon and Uganda you see in our
research we call what Moe Abraham built
a market creating innovation market
creating innovations transform
complicated and expensive products into
products that are simple and affordable
so
many more people in society could access
them now in this case phones were
expensive before sell tell made them
much more affordable
now as other investors some of his
colleagues actually saw that it was
possible to create a successful mobile
phone company on the continent and they
flooded in with billions of dollars of
investments and this led to significant
growth in the industry from barely
nothing in 2000 today virtually every
African country now has a vibrant mobile
telecommunications industry the sector
now supports close to 1 billion phone
connections it has created nearly 4
million jobs and generates billions of
dollars in taxes every year now these
are taxes that governments can now
reinvest into the economy to build their
institutions and here's the thing
because most people no longer have to
bribe public officials just to get a
phone corruption at least within this
industry has reduced
now if Mo Ibrahim had waited for
corruption to be fixed in all of
sub-saharan Africa before he invested
he'd still be waiting today you know
most people who engage in corruption
know they shouldn't and the public
officials who were demanding bribes from
people to get phones and the people who
were paying the bribes they knew they
were breaking the law but they did it
anyways the question is why the answer
scarcity
C whenever people would benefit from
gaining access to something that scarce
this makes corruption attractive you
know in poor countries we complain a lot
about corrupt politicians who embezzled
8 funds but in many of those countries
economic opportunities scarce and so
corruption becomes an attractive way to
gain wealth we also complain about civil
servants like police officers who extort
money from everyday hard-working
citizens but most civil servants are
grossly underpaid and a leading
desperate lives and so for them
extortion or corruption is a good way to
make a living you know this phenomenon
also plays itself out in wealthy
countries as well when rich parents
bribe university officials so they're
cheap when rich parents bribe university
officials so their children can gain
admission into elite colleges the
circumstance is different but the
principle is the same
I mean admission into elite colleges is
scarce and so bribery becomes attractive
the thing is I'm not trying to say there
shouldn't be things that are scarce in
society or things that are selective
what I'm just trying to explain is this
relationship between corruption and
scarcity and in most poor countries way
too many basic things are scarce I mean
things like food education health care
Economic Opportunity jobs this creates
the perfect breeding ground for
corruption to thrive now in no way does
this excuse corrupt behavior it just
helps us understand it a bit better
investing in businesses that make things
affordable and accessible to so many
more people attacks this scarcity and
creates the revenues for governments to
reinvest in their economies now when
this happens on a countrywide level it
can revolutionize nations consider the
impact in South Korea now in the 1950s
South Korea was a desperately poor
country and it was very corrupt the
country was ruled by an authoritarian
government and engaged in bribery and
embezzlement in fact economists at the
time said South Korea was trapped in
poverty and that and they referred to it
as an economic basket case when you
looked at South Korea's institutions
even as late as the 1980s they were on
par with some of the poorest and most
corrupt
African countries at the time but as
companies like Samsung Kia Hyundai
invested in innovations that made things
much more affordable for so many more
people South Korea ultimately became
prosperous now as the country grew
prosperous it was able to transition
from an authoritarian government to a
democratic government and has been able
to reinvest in building its institutions
and this has paid off tremendously for
instance in 2018 South Korea's president
was sentenced to 25 years in prison on
corruption related charges this could
never have happened decades ago when the
country was poor and ruled by an
authoritarian government in fact as we
looked at most prosperous countries
today what we found was they were able
to reduce corruption as they became
prosperous not before so where does that
leave us
I know it may sound like I'm saying we
should just ignore corruption that's not
what I'm saying at all what I'm
suggesting though is that corruption
especially for most people in poor
countries is a workaround it's a utility
in a place where there are fewer better
options to solve a problem investing in
innovations that make products much more
affordable for many people not only
attacks this scarcity but it creates a
sustainable source of revenue for
governments to reinvest into the
economies to strengthen their
institutions this is the critical
missing piece in the economic
development puzzle that will ultimately
help us reduce corruption you know I
lost hope in Nigeria when I was 16 and
in some ways the country has actually
gotten worse in addition to widespread
poverty and endemic corruption Nigeria
now actually deals with terrorist
organizations like Boko Haram but
somehow I am more hopeful about Nigeria
today than I've ever been before when I
see organizations
investing in innovations that are
creating jobs for people and making
things affordable
I mean organizations like Life stores
pharmacy making drugs and
pharmaceuticals more affordable for
people or metro Africa Express tackling
the scarcity of distribution and
logistics for many small businesses or
and elle' creating economic opportunity
for software developers I am optimistic
about the future I hope you will be too
thank you
[Applause]